so today I'm at the University of Sydney
with dr. Phil Dooley and we're talking
about how our idea of the atom change
from a tiny little hard sphere to
something more complicated and this
apparatus is something to do with that
exactly exactly it was quite a quite a
landmark historical experiment it's just
made of a tube of glass connected to a
vacuum pump and in the tube of glass
there are two pieces of metal connected
to a high-voltage power supply so so we
can suck the air out of here that's
right and then apply high voltage to two
metal plates yes normally with high
voltage in air we don't get anything
except maybe a big spark but what we
what Geisler found who did this in 1857
was something quite different so should
we have a look let's do it okay let's
turn on the pump and the high volts turn
off the lights so we can see what's
going on as you can see something's
happening now yeah I see a bit of a pink
glow in there that's right so imagine
guys for the first person to ever see
this it's pretty surprising that started
people thinking what is this stuff
that's coming from the cathode seem to
be a ray emitted from this negatively
charged one which they called the
cathode therefore it's called a cathode
ray and it became the topic for research
for the next 40 years as all the big
bigwigs of physics and science basically
tried to work out what was going on so
what did they figure out I mean what is
going on what's producing this this glow
here there were two main camps one
thought that it was waves and the second
thought that the electricity was being
carried by a stream of charged particles
over the next 40 years they basically
came to the conclusion well it was JJ
Thompson in 1897 who came up with the
idea that there is a stream of very
small charged particles negatively
charged
they're smaller than an atom so the
smallest atom hydrogen atom they're
about one thousandth of the size of that
and it doesn't matter what material it's
the metal is it's always the same
particle so this particle appears to be
in everything and yeah this electron as
it was as it was known is what's
carrying the electricity so Thomson came
to the conclusion that all atoms have
this particle as one of their
constituents that's right that's right
so it wasn't a billiard ball there had
to be something inside the billiard ball
hmm
so how do I picture like a billiard ball
with bits inside of them well you should
probably think about a pudding a pudding
yeah well that's what his idea was that
it was a plum pudding very dear to every
British person's heart that and inside
the pudding you have plums and plums can
come out of that so when you apply a
high voltage then a negatively charged
electron which Thompson pictured as a
plum comes out and leaves behind
positively charged pudding are you a fan
of plum pudding are for research
purposes definitely okay all right well
let's see if we can research this a
little further okay that sounds like fun